concert for a cause that's what I'm
calling it was really amazing Christina
Aguilera tried out a hot new look but
all eyes were on a very rare appearance
by none other and share we're in a white
hat the 70 year old singer post were
pics with John Legend Chrissy Teigen Eva
Longoria best on and ricky martin at the
she's with us concert for Hillary
Clinton share even got on stage sharing
a special moment with the presidential
candidate and joking about how she's
lived through 11 presidents equally
excited about the big event Eva I just
came back from honeymoon for this event
so I told my husband I'm like we've got
to get back for the California primaries
we could cut the honeymoon short and he
was like what but he understood they're
gonna be out there you know jam it yeah
I'm singing with Ricky tonight livin la
vida loca Roja no haha I was like
shebangs he was gonna make a special
appearance for shebang national appear I
let me tell you I was an extra in the
shebang video they wouldn't even let me
get close to Ricky they're like ma'am
ma'am we will fire you their way stay
away and now look at full circle moment
tonight right Circle Circle moment was
him at my wedding on stage singing with
me livin la vida loca and I did feel
like the girl in the video he do you do
you get a pup on that show tonight and
she did
other performers included John Legend
Stevie Wonder and Christina Aguilera who
debuted a brand new red do a la Jessica
Rabbit and belted out her classic ain't
no other man
[Music]